main street in pullman washington home
to washington state university
shows a glimpse of college town life
leading into this semester
in a typical fall the town population
swells to about 35
000 as more than 20 000 students report
for class
but this semester the on-campus
residence halls and apartments
will be virtually empty and the more
than thirty thousand seats in martin
stadium
will be two it's not just pullman
one study says as of mid-august the
coronavirus has pushed
nearly half of u.s colleges and
universities into some degree of remote
learning
that could mean fewer students and
visitors in college towns which could
lead to lower sales for restaurants
gas stations and hotels that's sending
shockwaves through the economies of many
college towns
[Music]
in pullman washington wsu dominates the
landscape
and the economy anna brown an economist
at mc
creates models of spending patterns in
college towns
so when we look at these analyses what
we want to look at is the new
economic activity created in a town or
in a region as a result of the
universities
so the operations spending impact is
what we call it tends to be one of the
largest
impacts and we especially see that with
wsu in pullman
brown's model says that the university's
day-to-day spending
brought 779 million dollars into
pullman's economy in a recent fiscal
year
that includes spending on staff payrolls
equipment purchases
and food and then how that spending
ripples through the local economy
the school's budget comes from a few
revenue streams including enrollments
and public funding
both are expected to be down in part due
to the coronavirus
washington state is asking public
universities to plan
for a 15 reduction in state funding for
the 2021 fiscal year
wsu's financial officer said that the
budget cut for the school
is roughly equal to the cost to run the
colleges of business
communication and education combined
similar losses could happen elsewhere in
the country
in california public colleges face 602
million dollars in reductions
the state of maryland imposed eight
percent cuts on higher education which
may reduce university spending as well
enrollment could stall or even be down
at some schools
potentially hurting school budgets and
interrupting spending on college town
communities
in the northeast the enrollment dip
could cause some schools to shudder
altogether
19 cities and towns in new england have
economies that rely on financially
vulnerable colleges
according to an analysis from the
federal reserve bank of boston
the financial health of a college town
depends on university spending
but student activity plays an important
role too
mc's analysis of pullman says student
spending had an impact of 48.5 million
dollars last year
that's equivalent to about 1200 local
jobs
this includes the spending that students
spend
for their room and board particularly
for off-campus students
as well as for their day-to-day expenses
as they're going to
local restaurants as they're spending
money on gas and so forth like
all of that is considered within the
student spending impact and really what
we're focusing in on there are students
who are relocating
to pullman or students who stay in
pullman because of wsu
if students stay away pullman businesses
will see fewer sales
and the city government will see less
tax revenues but the city administrator
of pullman
says that at least some students are
returning to their off-campus apartments
their activity could help offset the
impact of budget cuts
in conversations with the university
they're they're planning currently for
about 70
of the students to return and the
students are such a
huge impact on our our community i mean
they're they're residents most of the
time of the year as well so
anytime they're going out and spending
that that means a big impact
other schools are working with local
businesses to welcome students back
that could alleviate some of the
economic pain virginia tech is welcoming
students back to blacksburg
but off-campus students can't buy
on-campus meal plans
that could divert more spending toward
local restaurants and grocers
back out west moscow idaho is welcoming
12 000 students to attend
the university of idaho their campus is
10 miles away from wsu
that could draw more students into the
region helping mitigate some of the
economic damage
but the loss of fall sports could
significantly reduce visitor spending
in pullman visitors brought 17.3 million
dollars
into the local economy in a recent
fiscal year
during big football events there are a
lot of cougar fans who live
in the seattle area and so they are
coming from seattle every weekend or
every home game weekend
to watch the football game and so then
they're bringing that money with them
and that's creating uh
the economic impact by spending locally
and it's money that would not have
otherwise been spent
if not for the university home games or
other events such as graduation or moms
weekend and those types of events
but this spring as the country sheltered
in place events were called off
craig depkin a professor of economics at
the university of north carolina at
charlotte
says that game day spending from
visitors will be missed most in the
smallest college towns
let's say a town like prairie view texas
which has about five thousand
six hundred people some land roughly
around six thousand people in the town
that's a small town the economy is not
going to be very huge it will have its
fast food restaurants and it'll have his
gas stations then
you look at the football stadium at
prairie view a m if that stadium is full
it has more people in the stadium than
live in the entire town
one of his studies found that in smaller
college towns games can promote economic
growth
but prairie view a m's athletics
conference postponed fall sports
some of the biggest football conferences
are following suit
washington state university's pac-12
conference postponed fall athletics
as did the big ten with football season
postponed
college towns like pullman may see a
reduction in spending
as they could from their other two main
sources
spending in college towns will be down
this fall the expected slowdown and
activity
could eliminate vital jobs as fall
approaches
economists are watching
[Music]
you